від мін та інших вибухонебезпечних
предметів гинуть
діти жодна дитина не має ризикувати
повертаючись додому зі школи гуляючи в
парку чи на дитячому
[музика]
майданчику доки територія України
забруднена мінами наш обов'язок
розповісти дітям загрози та пояснити як
залишатися в
безпеці
Цей курс допоможе вам дізнатися як
ефективно та правильно навчати дітей та
підлітків правил мінної
безпеки я Поділюсь із вами чотирма
основними аспектами які ми висвітлюємо у
навчанні дітей мінній безпеці і яких
помилок часто припускаються у викладанні
та популяризації цієї теми які можуть
нашкодити
[музика]
дитині я розкажу вам як працювати з
учнями різного віку ви дізнаєтесь як
працює їхній мозок та як це впливає на
структуру і зміст уроку А ще поговоримо
про емоційну безпеку на заняттях про
таке середовище в якому дитині буде
спокійно і цікаво
[музика]
навчатися
я спільно з іншими фахівцями допоможемо
вам підготуватись до роботи з дітьми
викладання практичних курсів дітям
різного віку у різних форматах має деякі
особливості чому потрібно готувати
заняття для дітей різного віку
[музика]
по-різному я Поділюсь з вами
рекомендаціями Як побудувати в цікавій
та інтерактивній формі урок на безпекову
тему для дітей в сучасних умовах
викладання ви поповните свою методичну
скарбницю новими прийомами та засобами
викладання на уроках як наживо так і в
онлайн наша мета охопити кожну школу
кожен клас І кожну
[музика]
дитину реєструйтеся на сайті
безpekaкраінфо щоб підвищити свою
кваліфікацію спільно формуємо культуру
безпеки українських
[музика]
дітей